what's up guys so as you guys know a DS
Vegas series didn't do so hot and by
that I mean that it didn't do anything
empty 56 and 64 did match the
performance of some high-end nvidia gpus
but there really was no need to buy Vega
as opposed to the 1080 or other Nvidia
offerees especially with the Vega
drawing more power
AMD didn't really bring ultimate value
or really good performance to the Vega
series if anything they were able to
match in video and as a result it didn't
accomplish anything if we ask AMD
superfans then they'll tell you that
Omega was never meant to be in video but
instead just match it
however they have to realize that they
have to provide something superior to
the competition in order to attract
consumers finally the last blow to Vega
was the mining craze and this
effectively put an end to any hope of
Vega beating oh and video now oMG fans
are claiming that AMD Nami is Birds at
and that is how AMD will outperform
Nvidia so when is AMD Nabi expected to
come out and what can we expect from
Navi
well according to rumors there's
expected to be two Navi carts the single
and dual GPU card with a Navi tip knobby
ten times to the single barrage is
rumored to be produced in the seven
nanometer process which will deliver
more than 50 teraflops of half position
performance and 30 teraflops of single
precision the RAM rumors are all over
the place with this being rumored to
possess anywhere from 16 gigabytes of
RAM all the way to 128 gigabytes of RAM
but that is supposedly rumored to
possess next-gen memory whatever that is
by this they probably means GDD are six
memory the TDP is predicted to be from
150 to 300 watts finally this is
expected to take advantage at PCIe 4.0
but it is not expected to release till
2019 so it is still a wild out next up
for the dual variant
is rumored to be absolutely monstrous
this car is also rumored to be part of
the seven animated process however this
is rumored to deliver more than 100
teraflops of half position and sixty
teraflops of single position this one is
supposed to have anywhere from 32 to 256
gigabytes of next-gen memory finally
just like the single parent
this is rumored to utilize PCIe 4.0 and
this card is also not expected to come
out till 2019 well these specs sound
absolutely insane but usually rumors
don't hold out so just make sure to keep
that in mind while these pecs seem
insane Nvidia may have something just as
good or even better with their volta
GPUs so that's something to consider as
well if you guys are interested in volta
then make sure check out my dedicated
video on volta
but anyways as it is evident na'vi is
still really mostly in the dark but
hopefully it really is as great as that
is expected to be this competition is
always good for the consumer but
unfortunately these cards aren't coming
up any time soon and for right now we
have NVIDIA ampere turning and probably
the AMD 600 series to fill the void and
he may also come out with a mining
dedicated card but as you can see ambu
is very good at making mining cards and
mining it probably makes him a lot of
revenue and sales so they wouldn't want
to lose that market or the gaming market
so they probably will come up with a
mine dedicated GPU as well as they gave
me dedicated GPU just like what is
expected out of in video but that's
pretty much it for what you can expect
from AMD as far as GPUs go and next year
or two
well guys what do you guys think about
AMD na'vi do you think it will bring the
competition to Nvidia and make them
sweat like Intel right now or do you
think that all this is just over
exaggerated speculations for AMD
fangirls I do read all my comments and I
am curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts down
below also if you guys are interested in
any of this soon approaching GPUs like
Volta tiering ampere or AMD 600 series
then make sure to check out my videos on
each of them but that's all I
for you guys this time if you guys like
this view then make sure drop a like on
this video and if you guys loved it and
would like to see more video just like
this and make sure to smash that
subscribe button and hit doorbell
notification but until next time
[Music]